Some people claim that zakat on wealth
if above nisab has to be paid only once
in a lifetime.
If you have paid zakat on a particular
wealth or gold, you don't have to pay it
again next year. Is there a difference
of opinion in this matter?
Alhamdulillah.
As far as regarding the question, is
there a difference of opinion as far as
zakat should be paid once in a lifetime
or should be paid every year? In the
past 1,400 years, right from the time of
the Sahabas till the alfine
till late, never has there been any
scholar, any fukah who has ever said
that zakat should be paid only once in
lifetime. You read the Quran, you read
the hadith, the sayings of the prophet,
never will you find any hadith, any
Quranic verse, any scholar that has ever
said that zakar should be paid only
once. There's no difference of opinion
whatsoever. lately just a few years back
this issue has come to the picture and I
was there in Chennai a few years back
and the same question was asked to me
this originated from Chennai that's
south India this question was asked and
there was a local person who had raised
this issue
and there is ample of evidence
from the hadith that zakat should be
paid every year
and there's no question of difference
opinion and I don't know how this
controversy came up. If you read the
hadith of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, it's mentioned in Abu Daudi
number two book of zakat had number
1568.
The beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that if you have 200 dhams
and if you possess it for a period of
one year then you have to pay five dhams
that means 2 and a half% 140th of it and
there is no zakat on gold if you have
less than 20 dinars.
Now here it says that you have to pay
zakat if you possess it for one full
complete year. There's no mention that
you have to give once in lifetime. It
indicates that if you possess for two
years, you have to pay twice. If you
possess for three years, you have to pay
thrice. It's understood. If anyone says
that it has to be given once in
lifetime, there should be proof in the
Quran in the hadith which states clearly
and there are various other hadith which
clarify this issue. If you read the
hadith of
Abu Daudi number two book of zakat had
number 1577
the beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that anyone who has
three signs has seen belief the one who
worships only Allah subhanaa tala who
says there's no god worthy of worship
except Allah subhananaa tala and one who
pays zakat on his property agreeably
every year. So here the statement is
clearly mentioned every year that means
zakat should be paid every year. So
there is no difference opinion at all
and it's all authentic hadith
and furthermore there are various
references that can be given that can
easily disprove this point that it
should be paid only once in a lifetime.
There's a hadith mentioned in Bkhari
volume number two in the book of zakat
had number 1402.
You know some people argue that you know
zakat need not be paid on life talk and
etc etc. This hadith of say bkari number
in the zakat had number 1402 it says
that Mhamad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that
the animals of the livestock the camels
they will appear on the day of
resurrection in the healthiest form that
they have been in the world and will go
to the master to the owner and if you
have not paid zakat they will tread them
under their feet and the hadith
continues that the sheep They will
appear in the healthiest form that
they've been on this earth. And if the
owner has not paid zakat, they will but
them with their horn and will trample
them beneath the hoof indicating that
zakat should be given on these animals.
Further, if you read the hadith of Abu
Bakr Allah be pleased with him, it's
mentioned in say bkari number two in the
book of zakat had number 1399 and had
number 1400. There were some Arabs
who
did not want to give zakat and they
revolted.
So peace be with him. He said that he
will wage a war against these people.
May Allah be pleased with him said that
but the messenger of Allah said that
those who believe in Allah subhana wa
tala and don't worship anyone else and
those who sayoolah
we should not wage a war against them.
Abu Bakr may be him said that anyone who
breaks the law he'll wage a war against
them and anyone who differentiates
between salah and zakat that both are
compulsory he'll wage a war against them
and by Allah he says that anyone who
used to give a sheid or a lamb at the
time of the prophet and now is reluctant
to give or does not give that zakat
which used to get at the time of the
prophet he will wage a war against them
indicating that those zakat was given
last year, this year too it had to be
given and if they did not give Abu Bakr
Allah him he would wage a war against
them and Omar may Allah praise him says
that Allah subhanana wa tala had opened
the heart of Abu Bakr and what he said
was right indicating that zakat has to
be every year furthermore there are
various hadith how zakat used to be
collected and there's a hadith it's
mentioned Sai Bkari volume number two in
the book of zakat hadith number 1454
where a person says that he was
appointed by Abu Bakr may Allah be
pleased with him to collect zakat and he
said that the messenger of Allah
subhanaa t said how zakat should be
collected and he goes on saying that if
it's a camel if the number is five then
you have to give one sheep as zakat and
the number keeps on increasing and the
zakat keeps on increasing
if it's 40 sheep if anyone has a flock
of 40 sheep you should give one sheep as
zakat. Anywhere between the number of 40
to 120 the zakat is one sheep. If the
number of sheep between 120 and 200 two
sheep have to be given for zakat. If it
is between 200 and 300 three sheep have
to be given and for every 100 extra one
sheep has to be given. Now when the
collector of zakat went to collect the
zakat they used to count the livestock.
They used to count the head of the
cattle. They now looked for how many new
cattle have you got? How many new were
born? They counted all the cattle
available there. That means they even
took zakat on the cattle that were paid
earlier.
They didn't say okay this already last
year you gave so I'll not count that.
Please give me the number that you have
purchased lately or the new kids that
have been born or they should look out
for any goat or any sheep which is less
than one year old. that wasn't the case.
So this clearly proves that zakat has to
be given every year and it should be
given as long as you possess the wealth
for a period of one year and if the
nisab is above the level then you should
pay every year
and this idea that it should be given
once in a lifetime is a new idea which
has never heard before. It just came few
years back it's unheard of in the past
1400 years. So there's no difference
opinion whatsoever. Whichever group of
folk whatever they all of them agree
that faka should be paid every year.